so shireen's here with us and shireen i
thought of you last week because this
eli manning hall of fame question has
become front and center he announced his
retirement officially on friday at the
press conference you made a comment back
before the season about how
potentially this ongoing checking of the
box playing hanging around could at some
point diminish his chances of getting in
now that the hayes in the barn and i
know there's a five year waiting period
and it's not relevant until it's time to
really get into it but how do you feel
knee-jerk reaction right now with eli
manning walking away
and knowing again it's going to be five
years until you have to consider it but
your your first reaction thought on eli
getting in i don't think he's first
ballot and i do think there's a
difference some people will tell you
there is no difference i think there's a
difference between first ballot right
and later right i think he's a later guy
he's definitely not first ballot in my
mind and i won't vote for him probably
on first ballot again it's five years
away and but your first ballot is what
like really special like you got to be
somebody
there's not many of them and you don't
see many of them in a year but the
record bothers me but more than that
it's the four pro bowls everybody gets
in the pro bowl we have probably over a
hundred pro bowlers this year right and
he had four in his entire career i mean
dak prescott's played four years and has
two so that probably bothers me as much
as anything no all pros he's not gonna
be all decade you know all those things
bother me a bunch about eli i do think
he goes in yeah i just think there's
going to be a little bit of a wait and
people are going to be mad who are eli
fans that he's having to wait to go into
the house that's a good point it's one
thing to say he was never the best
quarterback in any given year of his era
because he's played in a special era
yeah but to say he never bubbled up to
the top three in the nfc or the
fallbacks when guys start tapping out of
the pro bowl
well that it's only happened four times
in 16 years that is kind of that is kind
of stunning to put in those terms it it
definitely is i i know like uh so i
agree with shireen i do think that he
gets in eventually right i do not think
he's a first ballot first ballot is for
like what what shireen talked about troy
palamala who's arguably one of the
greatest safeties ever ray lewis last
year who might be the greatest
linebacker ever those are first out
brady when he goes in see i thought
brian urlacher was maybe
i agree took a little way from ray lewis
i agree i did not think brian erlacker
deserved to be at first ballot hall of
famer hollywood away from ed reed ed
reed we're talking about and read two
exactly right there's another guy that
should be it should be and was a first
but but i i'm i'm on the fence like
personally i think right now as i sit
here and evaluate i don't know where you
are mike like okay right now end of
january 2020
i guess i would say he is a hall of
famer but i'm very much on the fence and
i don't sit here and just go oh yeah he
definitely is or not it's this is a
tough conversation i come back to yeah
your pro bowl conversation what i come
back to always is
i really don't know
other than 2011 if there was a year in
his career where you could say he was
one of the five best quarterbacks in
football and to me that speaks to hall
of famer that you know most hall of
famers are top three at their position
for a number of years absolutely and
that's where i i guess i struggle with
it where where you lay on this i don't
think we've really i'm very pragmatic
i'm very pragmatic yeah i understand the
realities of the process as shireen does
very well because she's in the middle of
it she gets lobbied
the bottom line is when i saw the video
from peyton manning
that appeared on the broncos official
website on the day that the news came
out that eli was retiring
you're going to hear from peyton manning
over and over again over the next five
years you're going to hear from archie
over and over again over the next five
years they are going to launch an
extended campaign to get eli in and at a
certain point they're going to get him
in the question is is it first time is
it second time is a third time that's
all that matters at this point and it's
the flip side of the chris carter and
the terrell owens argument where those
guys were delayed because nobody liked
them everybody everybody likes eli like
and his name's manning and he's going to
have peyton and archie constantly
pushing there's going to be people in
the media constantly pushing i just at
some point he's going to get the votes
to get in because the voters are just
going to be like we're sick of this
please end it end the campaign to get
eli in just put the guy in so we can
move on to other candidates that's why i
think he'll eventually get in oh and by
the way two of the greatest moments in
the history of the national football
league two super bowl mvps i mean those
are indelibly well so that's what i want
those are that would be my question like
because i always get like to me part of
the hall of fame right is like can you
tell the story of the nfl without that
guy
and i don't know if you can without eli
right and that's what i would go back to
is those two super bowls and those
moments and don't tell me he needs to go
in because he won two super bowls jim
plunkett is not in way to go
and that's what separates eli not the
two super bowls but the plays he made in
those super bowls to win those games and
win the super bowl mvp and who he beat
and who we beat that's right right kept
the patriots from getting to eight in
nfl history the patriots should have
eight there should be a 19-0 team yeah
that has half the roster in canton by
now well i mean the nfl 100 greatest
teams ever that 2007 patriots team made
a top ten i mean they didn't win the
super bowl and they made one of the top
ten greatest teams of all time so to
your point yes that was a special moment
for eli i i think you know i've moved
around the over under from three and a
half to zero point five i'm going to 1.5
the one over under on eli getting in is
one point five tries okay i would take
the over but yeah i'm right there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports